[Music]
okay have you ever done an interview on
a rollercoaster before I never have how
about you no this is definitely a first
for me so we're waiting for it to go
we're kind of multitasking yes yes
interview / gonna ride this ride yeah
very excited we're gonna make this place
fast and loose it's a gentleman trying
to save his fading very dangerous theme
park and salvage his relationship with
his fourteen-year-old daughter but in
the meantime there's a lot of stunts and
all the stunts are real no cutting on
the action no going to pads I went to
the emergency room a lot how many times
did you go to the emergency room I don't
know oh wow that's show business
Wow so you've really always liked you
know fans of Jackass know that you are
kind of committed to just hurting
yourself all the time lots of stunts
you're not really afraid to try anything
what yeah I think I got hurt on this one
why did get her on this one more than a
knee yeah yeah oh well here we go here
we go
let's see what this baby can do
[Music]
oh man you're the lifeguard should we
keep facing the water like God sort em
out
okay now we've got chris pontius joining
us over here how you doing I'm good good
are you
does this rod make you nervous yeah I'm
pretty scared are you scared yes
absolutely
now you guys have been friends for how
many years Wow 97 or 98 parties since 97
problems what does it feel like kind of
reuniting on the big screen together
though so much fun like he just like he
brought all the heat yeah it was like it
even like in in the shots he's great in
between shots
he's even better he just stopped yeah oh
when we be sitting around yeah I'd make
Spears for like all the crew members
this one day we were filming um and
these baboons came around and um they
had to have like two different PAS on
either end of the set to make sure two
baboons didn't run in and baboons are
gnarly like so we had I made Spears for
the PAS because they'll kill you you
know it's like I am but I like it I'm
scared I'm scared oh god it's like a lot
higher than I
it's fine Oh found it I don't know I
have mixed emotions
do you have mixed emotions I don't feel
amazing right now but I feel like
there's nothing I can do to get out of
it yeah there's only one way down yeah
I'm gonna see the whole Inland Empire I
just don't feel like I'm very secure oh
my god I can't believe we're still going
up let's do it again my god I kind of
felt like did something something gone
wrong I probably didn't look so cool Oh
again and try to look real cool I was
scared it was scarier than I thought it
would be
[Music]
[Applause]